this video is sponsored by Squarespace
stick around until the end of the video
to learn more about a deal they're
making available through my channel
it'd be fair to say I think that
prisoner workouts have caught the
imagination of the internet people are
thrown in the clinic with no equipment
who ostensibly think should be losing
weight getting skinnier but in fact the
opposite happens they build more muscle
strength and performance not only do
they manage to maintain the physiques
that they had before they went in the
clink but they actually come out
stronger and more aesthetic how can this
be possible there's more to it I think
than the simple fact that you've got
nothing else to do I think that the way
the prisoners train It actually Taps
into some really interesting functions
of the body resulting in Greater
strength and of all the things I've
tried of all the different experiments
I've run I think this type of training
is the closest thing I've found to a
kind of untapped well of extra
performance
so I've come to this old shipping
container I found near me because that
looks prison-y right
no so for example we have Charles
Bronson the guy who looks like Dr
Robotnik he went to jail and trained
with body weight training in his prime
he claimed to be able to do over 1 700
push-ups in under an hour then you have
Mike Tyson who went to jail and used
huge rep ranges of bodyweight squats in
order to develop incredibly strong legs
when he came out of jail he maintained
and even surpassed his previous physical
performance claiming that this training
protocol allowed him to deliver more
power in his punches Andrew Tate not a
huge fan but he claims that he trained
predominantly prior to going to jail
with body weight exercises push-ups and
the like and he really touched exercises
such as the bench press now I do believe
him on that and in spite of that he
manages to bench impressive numbers I've
seen a video of impressing 140 kilograms
for someone only doing push-ups many
people would assume that's impossible
and of course when he went to jail this
explains why he didn't instantly lose
his physique and in fact got bigger but
what's also interesting are the people
who train like prisoners so prisoners
perform predominantly bodyweight
exercises and that means things like
push-up pull-ups of course you and I
know that we can use calisthenics to
massively increase the resistance on our
bodies by manipulating lever lengths by
training with one arm we can do things
like planche push-ups pseudo-punch
push-ups we can do front levers one
armed pull-ups there's no need to go to
extremely high rep ranges however I
guess that they're being less
information available for many of these
people and the fact that calisthenics is
quite a niche sport means that many of
these prisoners trained with just really
really high repetition push-ups squats
and pull-ups and I would wager that they
often used short range of motion these
are the key factors that can really tap
into that additional performance we're
going to see why in a moment an example
is Herschel Walker who has this crazy
physique and claims that he got there by
just doing lots and lots of push-ups and
sit-ups
the great gamma a guy with an unbeaten
record of a huge number of fights he
could train against 40 or more opponents
in a single day without burning out
there's this huge rock that weighs over
1 200 kilograms it's called the gamma
Stone you can still see it in a museum
today and Legend has it the gamma would
Train by lifting this again many of
these things are just Legends and
speculation but when you hear enough of
these stories you start to think there
must be some truth to some of it and
Gamma would train using thousands of
Hindu push-ups and Hindu squats every
single day Flex wheeler is a legendary
bodybuilder from the Golden Era of
bodybuilding who didn't use body weight
training per se but used high high rep
ranges of squats but also leg press in
order to develop some of the most
infamous legs that were around in
competition at the time vastly alexiv
had a weakness in his back he had a back
injury to get around this he reportedly
would shut people out of his gym whilst
he was secretly trained with extremely
high repetitions really slow cadence of
his modified secret version of the back
hyper extension he emerged stronger than
ever and cured his back injury and the
guy has over 80 World Records
even knees ever toes guy Ben Patrick who
went from having severely damaged knees
to being able to do incredible Feats
with them leaping off of ladders and
landing in a city squat position and all
kinds of other stuff dunking with ease
he got there using a variety of methods
and I highly recommend checking out his
atg program but among these were just a
backwards walking step after step after
step of backwards walking light
intensity extremely high repetition
continuous time and attention just like
prisoner workouts I just want to throw
my hat into the ring because this was my
early experience of training like many
people I started out just doing push-ups
sit-ups and pull-ups in my bedroom but
being slightly obsessive I would do
hundreds of repetitions of push-ups by
the end I'd do single sets of 200
push-ups for three sets then I'd go on
to do Archer push-ups slow motion quasi
isometric push-ups after that I did a
lot for my biceps and my abs as well but
the pecs got by far the most attention
I'm not saying this was a balanced
program I've always had over developed
pets compared to the rest of my body my
point is that this kind of training
clearly gave me some kind of Advantage
specifically in that area so I truly
believe that this kind of training
really works so what is going on here
now I'm back at my garden we're gonna
try and work out a bit like a prisoner
and see what's going on here because I
think the key lies in the way that they
perform these super high repetition but
simple calisthenics movements
so what I trying to do a push-up the way
is commonly taught by calisthenics
athletes the proper way I'd get into a
position like this with my hands quite
narrow and I would lower myself in a
controlled manner until my chest or nose
touch the floor I push myself up
completely
and I push through my scapula here in
order to really get that full range of
motion the problem is here my pecs
getting a rest essentially they're not
doing any work they're resting on my
joints and the scapula conversely what a
prisoner workout push-up might look like
a slightly wider grip and then you just
perform them
like this
no control no range of motion just
bouncing and this looks bad on Surface
but if you look a bit deeper it has its
own unique benefits neither superior but
do you think you should use both
together
this is certainly how I started out with
my push-ups when I began training in my
room so what's happening here is you're
maintaining a contraction this is
continuous time under tension so
basically if you perform a push up
slowly and lock your elbows out and this
gives you a small opportunity to rest
your pecs to rest conversely if you
maintain that time and attention by
continuously pushing up within that
shorter range of motion then you don't
have that opportunity as such your pecs
are constantly Contracting and you limit
Venus return in other words blood begins
to build up and pool inside the muscle
this can create all sorts of things via
hypoxia which might be a great trigger
for hypertrophy this is why occlusion
training is such an effective way to
build big muscle even using lighter
weights it works in a very similar
manner but at the same time you might
also create more angiogenesis this is
the formation of new blood vessels
supplying the muscles with blood and
oxygen and nutrients but also shuttling
away waste products that can lead to
burnout and failure in other words
you're increasing your strength
endurance but also increasing your blood
apply to the muscles this makes sense
because if you're making it harder for
blood to get in and out of the muscles
then obviously the body might adapt by
making it easier for blood to get in and
out of the muscles also means you're
going to get a metabolic buildup create
more metabolic stress creating that burn
sensation creating that pump that can
also lead to a form of hypertrophy it's
one of the three major contributors to
hypertrophy that we know of alongside
muscle damage and mechanical tension
this ultimately means that you'll be
able to perform repetitions for longer
which is why when you practice this
you'll get better and better at doing
bigger and bigger rep ranges of push-ups
or whatever exercise it is you've chosen
but at the same time it also means that
afterwards you've got a greater blood
supply a greater supply of nutrients to
the muscle which in turn can help to
improve recovery and growth so this
might Aid with hypertrophy in a biphasic
manner so that you train and then you
recover and you grow the muscles bigger
quicker afterwards at the same time
there's a correlation between increased
blood supply to the muscles and
increased myonuclei increased satellite
cells and increase protein synthesis it
seems you might be able to create more
myonuclei by donating satellite cells
which in turn creates more opportunity
for protein synthesis to occur this
isn't shown precisely in the studies
what I'm doing here is connecting the
dots but we know that occlusion training
can increase angiogenesis we know that
continuous times of tension can work
like occlusion training we know
occlusion training results in Greater
hypertrophy and we know there's a
connection between increased blood
supply to the muscle and increased
satellite cells in myonuclei so if we
add it all up and if we look at all
these examples it seems very likely that
something like this is going on here the
myonuclei stick around for the long term
as far as we know and so too might those
increased blood vessels this might mean
that you actually can build muscle more
easily or regain lost muscle more easily
and even maintain muscle more easily so
this form of training could have
long-term implications for the rest of
your training if you go through a long
period of training like this early on in
your Fitness career then you might reap
the benefits for years and decades
afterwards and I think that's something
that's fortunately happened to me by
pure accident and has happened to many
other athletes and trainees as well
increasing blood supply might also help
to strengthen the tendons because the
tendons generally have a lower blood
supply versus Muscle which make them
slower to adapt to training and slow to
recover from injury but by creating more
blood supply we might be able to
overcome some of these issues Beyond
this this kind of training these
extremely high rep ranges could also
create positive neurological adaptations
that's because we're rehearsing the
movement so many times as power satsulin
says strength is a skill in other words
the movements you perform whether it's a
bench press or deadlift these are skills
in themselves that require rote
repetition to learn this is especially
true for a lot of advanced calisthenics
movements the same is true for a push-up
if you want to get better at push-ups
you just practice doing push-ups
ignoring all that stuff like muscle
damage if you're doing hundreds and
hundreds of push-ups every single day or
multiple times per week then of course
this is going to result in you becoming
better at push-ups and what it might
also do is transfer over to some other
skills like bench press because what
you're essentially doing here is
training intramuscular coordination
you're teaching yourself to better
recruit the muscle fibers the motor
units that you need to perform that
movement you're getting better at
pushing and you only have to adapt that
a little bit to apply it to a bench
press or something else like that this
could go deeper still when it comes to
reaching failure because those people
who go to these extremely high rep
ranges are often doing it to failure you
might even find some ways to get past
failure by dropping to your knees and
continuing to do the push-ups what
happens here is that you've fatigued and
utilized all of the motor units all of
the muscle fibers that you can in order
to perform those repetitions but if you
try and push through if you try and
perform extra reps even at this point of
failure what you're doing is you're
teaching your central nervous system to
recruit more motor units more muscle
fibers when it needs it to go beyond its
maximum and then when you perform a one
rep max later on at the gym potentially
you can recruit more motor units to
perform that one rep max slightly easier
you've essentially just increased that
signal so you can shout to the muscles
louder to produce force and the way
we're performing this is essentially
almost like a plyometric we're
performing these bobbing push-ups as you
see what I'm doing is I'm going down to
the bottom of the movement and bouncing
back up the strength curve has changed
this is a negative in some ways but it's
also positive because it means that I'm
developing power from that lower
position this then translates to the
kind of bouncy performance you guys have
seen me do my kind of bouncing hand
springy push-up sequences before that
comes from doing this kind of training
it's made my pecs really explosive and
by increasing your rate of force
production and your explosiveness this
might transfer more to punches and
things but even some of the big lifts
where being able to generate that
massive amount of force in order to then
carry the weight through the range of
motion can be really useful especially
if you're like bouncing the weight off
your chest with the vest Etc so yeah in
short you might think that performing
this kind of cheat versions of push-ups
is a bad thing and in some ways it is
but at the same time it might just be
the secret to The Incredible strength
and performance we see in some prisoners
now I don't want to make any sweeping
statements some of these things are
based on myth and rumor and you know who
knows what else they actually got up to
in those jail cells but the point is
there seems to be some kind of benefit
to doing super super high rep
calisthenics and all these ideas I think
explain why that might be and also gels
it also makes sense with my own personal
experience
but they don't exclusively train this
way because it's not a full package in
terms of performance whilst you'll build
explosiveness and strength and size
you're not going to have that full
control you'd get by properly going
through the range of motion the full
range of motion at the same time there's
only certain body parts we can train
this way so what I recommend is that
within the same workout you combine
extremely high rep push-ups extremely
high rep squats and you put this with
much Fuller range more controlled slower
versions of those exercises maybe even
quasi isometrics where you take a whole
minute to perform a single repetition
this is again something I actually did
intuitively as a kid I called it time
division similarly I would say that
there's no reason to necessarily do 200
300 repetitions what you can do instead
is to do a few repetitions of a harder
variation and then to do lots and lots
of lighter faster repetitions likewise
you might decide to do some heavy dips
and then perform lots and lots of
push-ups or some weighted push-ups then
push-ups you're not actually in a prison
so you can do these things and this will
just get you to that point of failure
much quicker while still training those
same things I actually build this right
into my super functional training
program 2.0 the protein performance
system by using what I call Gauntlet
sets where you start on the hardest
variation of an exercise and end on the
easiest but with higher rep ranges to
fill out a total count if you're
interested in that you'll get most of
these benefits and that's why I've
designed it that way there's a link in
the description down below it comes with
over two hours of instructional video
and an 80 plus page ebook it's also
important when you do these high high
rep exercises you are sticking to closed
chain movements that means that you have
your hands and legs on Solid Ground at
the same time they should be stable
movements you don't want to be doing
high high repetitions of pistol squats
for example because that requires a
balanced component a Mobility component
and it's just a recipe for rendering
yourself this is something we see with
Crossfit what they're doing here is this
kind of high rep work against resistance
which I think is really really good but
because they're using movements that are
a little bit more dangerous some Olympic
lifts for example that's where we start
to see the accidents so this works you
just need to do it using the right kind
of exercise Hindi squats arguably
because you're on the balls of your toes
they're not that stable for me
personally it's not something I have
much of an issue with but your manager
may vary so ease into this stuff
likewise especially if you've got weak
knees finally I will also say that these
workouts these prisoner workouts are
going to lead to some imbalances and
they're not very Complete because if
you're training with just your body
weight especially if you're just
following the classic like sit-ups
Pull-Ups press-ups routine that seems to
come straight from one punch man what
you want to do is throw in some
rotations some movement in the
transverse plane and you can do that
with a kettlebell by doing swings
otherwise you're gonna have to do kick
throughs with high repetitions which is
tiring but can be really good
now I wouldn't say I have a lot of
experience when it comes to hashtag
prison life but I do know that if you're
gonna survive you need a posse
fortunately
I have the best
cellmate in the world
kill
you might remember him as my son from a
previous video he's all out of nappies
now and doing crimes with his power I've
actually been training with him like
this ever since then I think he reminds
me of a coconut called char
from a different YouTube channel and if
you can name me that YouTube channel
then kudos for having great taste in
YouTube channels
likewise you really want to pick
something up off the ground and
strengthen your hip hinge and your lower
back and a great way to do that is what
kettlebell swings a great one for the
shoulders is the Kettlebell Halo so what
I'm basically saying is that by just
adding a kettlebell which is technically
cheating if we're in prison but we're
not in prison unless you are in prison
in which case saws if you're not in
prison then you can add a kettlebell to
your routine it's a little bit cheating
spending the rules but it's going to
give you those other options and I do
think it has the kind of you know
prisoner appeal it's a kind of grungy
piece of equipment I don't know what I'm
talking about dear that's how you can
start applying these principles and
that's why I think the prisoner workout
is such a powerful modality and one that
we all could incorporate especially by
combining with others like maximum
strength training cardio and advanced
calisthenics skills we do this together
I think you're going to see amazing
results
so there it is that's what I think is
the secret to prisoner workouts and just
to high repetition calisthenics body
weight training in general I think it's
a powerful powerful tool that's
overlooked by a lot of the fitness
Community let me know in the comments
down below what you think do you agree
with me head over to patreon if you'd
like to support the channel and get
access to the exclusive Discord server
if you're in the highest tier there we
talk about all things related to Human
Performance productivity training brain
training Etc and for the top two tiers
I've just added a behind the scenes look
at the making of this video where I talk
about the filming process and how I
fitted it into my day about my training
my eating schedule Etc if you'd like to
check that out then yeah put the link in
the description down below either way
thank you so much for watching this one
guys and I'll see you next time bye for
now
so this has hopefully been a bit of fun
and maybe quite interesting and useful
but it's no laughing matter if you are
in jail and if you are in jail then
something great you can do is to build a
website with Squarespace today's sponsor
it's a great way to keep yourself busy
when you're trapped in a small room and
a great way to stay in touch with the
outside world I don't even know if this
is allowed by the way but seemed like a
sensible segue by the way Squarespace is
a website building platform and tool
that makes it extremely easy for anyone
to build a website and I'm talking in a
matter of minutes you might think that's
an exaggeration when you hear people say
it but it's actually really that simple
you can have a professional looking
website that quickly that easily thanks
to their fluid engine you can just drag
and drop elements into the design making
it easier than ever to really quickly
mock up your website you can work from
existing templates to get ideas and to
streamline the process and then edit
them to heart's content has all the
features you could possibly want gated
members only content for example
appointment scheduling e-commerce
features social media integration
Advanced formatting literally anything
you could want and you can expand this
even further with third-party plugins
adding things like Inventory management
to your e-commerce Suite or global
Shipping and tracking whatever the case
Squarespace has you covered so if you'd
like to check it out head over to
squarespace.com and when you're ready to
launch go to squarespace.com forward
slash bioneer and you'll get 10 off your
first domain or website thanks again to
Squarespace for sponsoring this video
thanks to you guys
and bye for now